[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host kristy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money this is an exciting
week around ramsey we are doing a whole
bunch of things i started off my weekend
in orange county in anaheim
speaking for east side church tens of
thousands of folks attending their four
campuses
and five services it was an absolute
blast wonderful people thanks to pastor
gene and barbara for
having us out there and taking the
entire church through financial peace
university um
always fun to meet with people who are
winning we're meeting people are just
getting started we're meeting people who
are baby steps millionaires and
just getting to hang out with folks
between services and sign stuff and take
pictures and hear stories and it's just
enthralling i love it i love it and for
those of you that haven't been to
california in a while i was under the
impression california's more shut down
than it is it was actually pretty open
um people were like normal and
everything
and uh i kind of had the impression they
weren't so i mean not i mean they're
california
but as close to normal as california is
going to be their version of normal
version of normal but i mean i mean i
thought the whole place was mashed up
and they were all sitting in their
houses or something and i i was wrong
they're they're pretty much we went to
restaurants that you can't get in
it's busy and everybody's out doing life
which is good i'm glad you guys are out
doing life i'm glad in spite of your
governor
so
big big week around here continues
tomorrow is launch day street date uh
for our latest publishing endeavor
christy wright's brand new book that
will be a number one called take back
your time the guilt-free guide
to balancing your life and
you can balance it's possible but you
have to understand what it really is
we're going to be talking about that a
lot this week
you can get the book at
ramseysolutions.com
including 50 worth of items only until
midnight tonight because tomorrow once
the book is on sale it's 20 for the book
that simple today you get 20 for the
book and 50 worth of stuff which
includes the ebook the audiobook access
to the live event that christy and i
will be doing on thursday night which is
another part of this big week uh we've
got about 21 seats left here in our
auditorium for the live in studio
portion and we're live streaming the
take back your time live event that
christy is doing and i think i'm doing
the intro or something like that yeah
you're doing the intro and anybody that
pre-orders before midnight tonight gets
a ticket to that so you can live stream
it or if you're in nashville come join
us in nashville we'll be doing a book
signing for those people that are the in
studio audience it's a launch party i'm
speaking you're speaking so it'll be a
lot of fun and if you're if you're uh
waiting on the audiobook i've had a lot
of people tell me dave they're waiting
on the audiobook i'm like pre-order now
you get the audiobook free and you'll
get a hardback copy of the book so uh
you get the ebook audiobook and a ticket
to thursday night's event yeah you'll
pre-order today you'll be able to
download all that within 24 hours yes
yes in less than 24 hours now and the
book will ship out tomorrow or it may
ship out today yeah because we just
don't want you to have it before lunch
day that's all because we told the
bookstores not to put it out until then
so it's a bit it's a big launch day for
take back your time
and
here's the thing we live in a culture
we were actually talking about this this
morning the great resignation ken
coleman's dealing with that a lot with a
number of people that have had an
existential experience where they kind
of stopped and went wait a minute this
pandemic thing made me realize i may not
get out of this whole thing alive and so
maybe i ought to work on crap that's
important to me rather than just work
yeah and so people are resigning 2.7 of
americans resigned their job last month
wow that's 36
of americans if that if you annualize
that yeah in one year will turn over
that's a record nothing like that has
ever been seen in modern times in
america and so but what that tells us is
is that we're pulled at 62 directions
and we're not always working on what's
in we think is important and something
like a pandemic has to say whoa right
what's important well it makes you
rethink your life you know sometimes i
think that we wake up we pour a cup of
coffee and we just run so hard and we
don't stop to think am i filling my
calendar my to-do list
with anything worth doing or am i just
reacting to everyone pulling at me and
the the truth is most of us are running
so hard and so fast reacting and so
there's there is something about the
pandemic but there's also something
about the the heart behind this book of
going hey you get one
life
how you spend your time
is how you spend your life so i want to
help you figure out what's important to
you and actually do that because it
turns out when you do what matters to
you that's what makes you feel balanced
at the end of the day anyway and so it's
really bringing a new take on this
balance equation and getting to the root
issue of what's going on which i believe
is what's really going to help people
yeah i had an old football coach friend
of mine you know he said he always
quotes james he said you're just here
for a vaper yeah
just here for a vapor you're just going
to be here for a second so you better
you better make you better make the most
of that dash yeah between the date you
were born and the day is over you better
make the most of that dash take back
your time yeah and uh you know what did
you do with it did you do it on purpose
and um as sharon and i over the years as
we've grown this business and had all
these different uh
uh things pulling at us yeah things that
quote unquote needed us and
um sharon's always saying well you're
not the messiah that's his job you don't
have to be everywhere uh that's god's
job he you can't be god you're not jesus
just stay home it's okay and um
and yet you want to get things done you
want to accomplish stuff you want to
step into things that have meaning but
we've had to learn at our house to
control our calendar
with almost more intensity than we do
our budget yeah well well there's a
finite aspect to your time that you
don't have with money you can earn more
money you can't get more time we all get
the same 24 hours in a day so it is the
most finite resource that we have so how
we manage it becomes a major factor in
our ability to be successful reach our
goals and just live our lives like we
want to and i think one of the
interesting things dave you know our
email team here our research team
marketing teams they're all into
seo search engine optimization they know
some of the top search terms and the top
search terms are productivity efficiency
you know multitasking and i'm going man
we think the solution is just to work
harder work smarter multitask have the
right app have the right morning routine
and just do more and it turns out we can
do all that and just end up exhausted so
i want to help you actually get out of
the rat race of just thinking that doing
more is going to solve your balance
problem because it's not i want to help
you figure out what matters to you and
do that and it turns out that's what
leads to that feeling you've been
wanting but it's a different path than
most of us are pursuing every day to be
honest so get all the free stuff do it
before midnight tonight um that sounds
like an infomercial or something but it
is i mean we shut it off at midnight
because tomorrow is officially the
launch day so the book is take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance it's 20 it includes the live
stream event or if you want to be in
studio you can do that for the event
this coming thursday night for christy
and i uh we're looking forward to that
all you got to do is just go to dave or
to ramseysolutions.com
and you can pre-order the book and you
can sign up for anything you want to do
if you put slash time after it it'll
bring up the uh the live stream event
and you can register for the live stream
event but there's no need to pay for
that just get the book
and the live stream is free
and the ebook
is free and the audiobook is free if you
do it right now this is your we've been
telling you for months weeks whatever do
it right now
now
ramsay solutions.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and
author of the brand new book take back
your time the guilt-free guide to life
balance is my co-host today justin is in
charlotte north carolina hey justin
what's up in your world
hey danny how are you great man how are
you
doing well doing well
um
i just had a quick question i started
working as a second job about five or
six weeks ago just to take care of some
bills and just kind of
lower our monthly
dues as you would
i currently owe 15 000 on my truck
18 thousand on my wife's car
and uh roughly a hundred thousand on the
house um i'm bringing home anywhere from
seven hundred to eleven hundred dollars
a week extra
and every friday
for the past five weeks i've been paying
that directly to my truck on top of the
monthly payment that i normally make am
i making the right move here yep
you're doing great what are your side
hustles
uh it's my old welding welding gig it's
uh right around the corner from my house
and uh
they just stay super busy so i can just
kind of roll in there when i want and
uh help them and they help me just as
much yeah you're doing awesome that's
amazing so all just your welding is is
that profitable that's awesome man
that's an extra 50 grand a year i mean
that's pretty incredible yes sir yeah
nice side hustle you know uh uh
so the big thing here is not only do you
want to throw the side hustle money on
there you want to be doing a budget that
includes everything coming in side
hustle money and all your money
both of you are making and then you
spend all of that money on paper with
your every dollar app
it's free to use
and you give every dollar an assignment
and any dollars that are left over
above one thousand dollars save for baby
step one are going to your smallest debt
which is your truck
and so yes you're correct to throw this
money but i'm challenging you there may
be some even more money in your budget
when you start living on a written game
plan that you and your wife are agreeing
to you'll feel like you've got to raise
you may find some more dollars there the
other thing justin keep in mind is that
when we talk about becoming debt free
and baby step two we're talking about
all debt except for the house that's a
different baby step and so you're doing
great just tackle those cars in baby
step two like you are one at a time with
your side hustle money and any extra
money that you can squeeze out of the
budget from your full-time job and
you'll be debt-free soon you're doing
great making all that extra income so
well done
yeah i mean if you're making
you're going to be there in
six months yeah you got 33 000 bucks
left on these cars you're going to be
done pretty quick and then you go and
finish your emergency fund at three to
six months of expenses baby step three
four as you start saving fifteen percent
towards retirement and we start to work
our way towards baby step millionaires
that next move then kayla is with us in
indianapolis hi kayla how are you hi
dave and christy how are you guys great
what's going on
um so i'm currently pregnant i'm due uh
november 10th with my second son
and this part around i'm doing things a
little differently i'm doing things the
dave way so we're about ready to start
um baby step one and it really makes me
nervous to only have
a thousand dollars one piece here so i
was wondering if we could stay in
historic mode for say six months
um just to get enough for once he's here
and make sure everything's okay and then
we jump into baby step two i know that
the thousand dollars is supposed to push
you and give you that momentum but it
just really makes me nervous only having
a thousand dollars with a new board
well to start out with um
the uh
we tell you not to do
a and not to do pay money on debt while
you're pregnant so just pile up as big
as you can pile until november 10th but
now you've had a baby this is your
second one this is not a mystery
which is exactly why i'm asking this
question i mean i mean what did you have
how did your life financially turn
upside down in the first six months
they just eat formula and diapers
true but i didn't have a very supportive
partner we're no longer together and he
actually doesn't even help with with my
son so that's not the case with my
husband but i'm saying i know what can
happen and like if something happened
with my car
if something happened with my car your
car babies break cars
no they don't but if i needed that money
for him i'm just i'm just not sure if a
thousand dollars is sitting on a
thousand dollars you don't need that
money for him you needed it for the car
a minute ago
kayla
let me jump in here let me jump in here
okay
so the the mindset typically when we
talk about saving up while you're
pregnant is the idea is to get the baby
safely here when your baby is safely
here which is what we would pray for and
hope for for you you've done this before
that's the idea then once the baby's
here and you've adjusted and you give
yourself a minute then yes you can go
back to paying off debt because
things are different now now what i hear
in your question and maybe i'm reading
into it but what i hear in your question
is kayla you've got some wounds from how
this went last time you didn't have a
supportive partner last time you had to
do things on your own that was scary and
that that fear is still with you and i
hear you but what we encourage people to
do is we want you to make decisions
based on facts not on fear right now
sounds like you're in a great situation
you've got some money saved up you're
going to keep saving up when the baby is
here safely you can begin to pay on that
debt again and you will be bringing this
baby home with a supportive
spouse in a different situation so i
just want to encourage you yes that fear
taught you something but we don't have
to live in that fear and worry because
there's no amount of money that's going
to relieve that fear that that seems
like that's that past wound talking to
me and the idea is we want to get that
baby here when you get the baby here
safely you can start to pay on that debt
again once baby's here and safe in your
situation hon
the reason i'm poking at you is 99 of
your world is predictable
it is it is formula diapers and
pediatrician bills and they become part
of the budget
and you don't need an emergency fund for
those things and there's not there's no
boogie monster in the closet there's
just not um does maternity leave factor
into that at all unpaid maternity leave
that's another reason i guess you're
gonna have to put that in your budget
right
okay i mean if you guys can you live on
his income
um yeah i believe so it would be very
tight right now we make around 90 000
both of us what does he make
he makes
that take home for both of us he makes
85. okay on his own and that's not and
you make five five
he comes about five thousand a month for
him for me it's almost four thousand a
month i'm sorry i'm uh oh i thought you
said he made 85 000 a year
he does that that's not take-home though
his take home is is about five so 43 you
can live on 85 000 a year
with two babies
you can do it why do you feel like you
can't kayla do you have too much house
or she doesn't have a budget that's why
she doesn't so you're you're dealing
with all these emotional stuff and
you're dealing with no facts at all
and you're dealing with the past wounds
that christie's talking about and you've
got this vague thing in your head you
just told me your husband makes eighty
five thousand dollars a year and you
have two kids if you miss out a little
bit of income while you have oh you're
out on maternity leave zippy
tighten up the old belt and stay out of
the restaurants
you can do this that's a very very very
doable okay um
so yeah
don't add pregnancy drama to this
discussion it's just all you gotta do is
lay out these numbers and and walk it
straight through this is very doable
christie's done it rachel's done it
you've done it you can do it
and the one thousand dollars is not a
problem not a problem at all open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five christy wright is my co-host
today
thank you for jumping in it is a free
call and so here's the thing when you're
having a baby or you've got some kind of
known
uh big event yeah that's a that could be
financially negative having a baby is
not negative but i was going to say
negative big event but it's financial it
can be we tell you to stop right your
baby steps push pause right
and then push play
and
when the baby comes and comes home and
take any money above a thousand and
throw it at your debt snowball and the
reason we do that is you do have a
predictable set of circumstances then
right and it could be that you're out on
maternity leave and the predictable set
of circumstances is we have to live on
the 85. but that is a not an
unreasonable thing and in no way are we
putting your family at risk
with a thousand dollar balance you make
a good point the unknown is what is
scary to people if you have a budget and
you can see how you can make it work
it's not scary anymore because you can
see on paper that's why we tell you guys
to do a written budget in every dollar
budget when you see it
you can do it it takes the fear of the
unknown out of it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage adam and alyssa are with
us hey guys how are you hi we're doing
great great where do you guys live grand
rapids michigan very cool welcome to
nashville in here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off we
paid off 460 000 whoa whoa
how long did this take nine years okay
and your range of income during that
time we started off at 80 between the
two of us and this past year we were at
275. oh
what do you guys do for a living
i'm now a director of operations for a
cancer center in michigan
and i work in oil and gas pipelines okay
and you guys are in grand rapids yes wow
very cool so i'm guessing with these
numbers you paid off your house
debt free completely i love it
very cool what's this house worth
now it's worth about 400 000. okay
phenomenal so 460 includes the house and
some other stuff then it does he had
student loans when we first got married
almost 10 years ago
we had a car that we bought
with a loan which we won't do again but
we paid that off
i went to school i have one and a half
got one and a half masters completed but
all right so a variety of things all
right cool so how much of the 460 was
the house
um 90 percent yeah well yeah 290. okay
so 300 of it or 400 okay or so wow way
to go guys that's awesome so what
happened what happened nine years ago
that got you guys on this kick to not
only pay off the student loans the other
debt but all of it we got married okay
and i had paid off my student loans i
had a house he had a house and we just
we're trying to figure out how to make
it work together what do we do for a
budget
are we going to save we wanted kids i
actually got pregnant a month after we
got married so oh wow yeah it was
something
wow and we just yeah we were looking for
a plan and
kind of fell into this it was simple for
us to think about
we could do it
um
but we changed jobs a lot we
he got me into management and healthcare
which has just kind of made my career
take off
and i got laid off uh or fired three
times
okay due to the downturn okay and then
uh someone asked me to come back and
then it's just been
work work work yeah without getting
divorced so yeah
how'd you get connected with us on the
plan for the plan
my old boss from out of college would
listen to you guys and he
it made sense he had money so yeah as
dave said you listen to people who have
money not those that don't yeah
and uh
i just kind of started following it just
a really small shuffle yeah
we also like the biblical basis i think
too you know we try to teach our kids
why we do what we do and to us that was
really important to have something that
wasn't just to get more money but
there's
you know philosophy behind it that means
more so that was important to us too
yeah how's it feel to have paid for
everything house and everything so
awesome
it's really good it's awesome free
yeah every
different different level of weight
around your shoulders huh
yeah yeah very cool what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is nine years you've been working on
this
communication
hard work and communication
get a bigger shovel and have a spouse
that supports you when you're traveling
yeah yeah so you've been gone a lot huh
uh last year was 90 days in a hotel whoa
and then this year's um
27 so far wow wow
that's enough
you know people who think traveling is
glamorous don't do it right yeah that's
true
we are for this trip uh well there you
go yeah this one you need to clamber it
up a little yeah yeah this is not it's
not pipeline trip here this is a
celebration trip i like it that's
awesome what kept y'all motivated this
is a long haul nine years in the house
like that's that's even more than a
marathon like this is ultra marathon
what kept you motivated
i think our commitment i mean we have a
book every year that we write down what
our goals are and
where we want to be and we have four
kids now
and so that's that's my motivation is to
be stable show them how to do it right
um how to stick to a commitment
what's the age range
one to eight oh okay wow yeah very fun
yeah good for you guys well this is
fabulous you guys yeah we're so proud of
you
very very well done heroes four kids and
a paid off house and everything all in
just 10 years you've been getting after
it nine years for that matter yeah well
well done very cool and uh well we
appreciate you coming down here
celebrating with us hope you have a
great time here in nashville we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is the next chapter in your story for
sure to be everyday millionaires
wait a minute are you all ready
we're like
forty thousand dollars away forty years
you're there round up round up
okay so with a paid for four hundred
thousand dollar house and then six
hundred thousand in nest egg yeah yeah
and you're there and how old are you
he's turning 40 on saturday all right
happy birthday thank you not a bad
birthday present millionaire
stock market just needs to go up a
little between now and friday you'll be
there right yes i like it this is great
way to go you guys that's awesome i'm so
proud of you well we're seeing a lot of
that these days and uh especially when
they come in to do their paid off house
as a part of the debt free screen
that sets you up to be here so very very
well done i love it well we got a copy
of legacy journey for you because that's
been your motivation change your legacy
and you have
and uh you'll enjoy that book and of
course total money makeover for you to
give to someone else and maybe you're
the old guy with money now that some
young guy's listening to at work
watching you
you hand them off that total money
makeover and we'll get them going and 10
years later i'll have them in here right
so very good stuff i love it all right
adam and alyssa grand rapids michigan
house and everything
baby steps millionaires 460 000 paid off
in nine years making 80 to 275. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three
yeah
that's how it's done
that is so cool the house man it gets me
every time and we are getting that more
and more you and i've talked about this
this is
30 years of you teaching this stuff yeah
and it started you're starting to see
people you know baby steps kids and
babies millionaires and people paying
off the house it's becoming
more and more normal for people to be
completely debt free which is pretty
incredible
well let's inject our typical numbers
under the situation we didn't ask them
about it but it won't be far off nine
years 460 of that
a little over 300 was the house and so
let's say it took them three years of
the nine
to get the other stuff done baby steps
one through three debt-free have an
emergency fund in place and maybe two
years somewhere in there and then
they've got six to seven years they get
the house paid off which is about
typical also right of people following
the total money makeover baby steps
doing financial peace university doing
this kind of stuff they knock it out in
about seven years and you're sitting
there with a half million dollar house
and this is very typically what we find
during that time
from baby steps four five and six you're
putting fifteen percent of your income
away right do that for seven years with
matches and roths and good mutual funds
and good rates of return uh and they're
making really good money their incomes
are increasing during this time fifteen
percent of that while paying extra on
the house
gets you to a nest egg six seven hundred
thousand with a paid for house of four
hundred thousand those two things added
together with one hundred percent debt
free equals one million dollars or
greater net worth you are a baby steps
millionaire yeah this is how it happens
all the time yeah yeah and i think i
wonder how many people too are
right at that baby steps millionaire
mark and they may not even realize it
because their situation has changed just
in the last three years even whether
it's from their investments their
retirement their uh home guys oh you're
the home yeah growing up they put them
over the line and they don't even
realize it and so it's just incredible
how quickly that can change when you
follow the baby steps well the number of
people that aren't actually focusing on
the number instead they're just focused
focusing on doing the work the principal
yeah and then they look up and go whoa
we did it it worked yeah we're there
look at that
there it is there it is yeah and it just
it sneaks up on you the number of times
i hear that as well is it's pretty
typical yeah uh again for for a baby
steps millionaire and we're finding
these folks everywhere and we've known
they were there
and they kind of did portions of the
plan on their own but now after almost
30 years of being on the air
we've they followed us we followed them
all the way through to where now we've
got this affinity with this particular
group that's pretty incredible and uh
they're everywhere and they're proof
that you can do it that's the point
that's exactly right if you're listening
you're watching you can do this you
could be 22
and be 32
and have gotten there
that could happen
wow how wicked weird is that
that's like becoming wealthy and stuff
and stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today evanston wyoming shelley
is calling hi shelly welcome to the
ramsay show
hi
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
i my husband and i just finished baby
step three on saturday yay
congratulations we are so excited thank
you
but we have a question about baby step
four we don't have children at home so
we're not
baby step five isn't relevant for us
but my husband has a very generous
pension plan
he makes about a hundred twelve thousand
a year
in retirement
and so we're trying to figure out if
it's reasonable for us to not worry
about that for we don't have earned
income so we can't do an ira or anything
like that we need to do a mutual fund
should we just skip over to six and and
focus on paying off our house how old
are you guys
he's 57 and i'm 54. why do you have no
earned income
um
he said you know he's going to ask me
that and i our our reason is when he
retired three years ago we bought a
foreclosed townhouse and we're spending
our time
remodeling it to build up some equity he
retired from the military
and so we didn't have any kind of equity
or anything like that
so we brought this townhouse and we're
remodeling it it was in really really
rough shape so we're doing a lot of work
on it and focusing on that and and
cool
when will that be done
hopefully by the end of
2022
we'll have everything that we want
finished finished and we've been cash
flowing all that along the way yeah and
what do you owe on the property
we owe 99. okay all right
and we have probably about i don't know
maybe fifteen thousand dollars worth of
work we still wanna take survivorship on
his military pension
yes
okay
so it goes from 112 to 80 when he dies
right
okay
um that's what scares me
is that uh something happens to him
before you guys execute your plan
right and you're living on his
survivorship pension until you go get a
career
and you've still got 100 and you've
still got debt on the house and you've
still got absolutely no money
other than an income
right and that just scares me i just it
doesn't feel like a solid plan
okay
so i want you to start building up a
nest egg i appreciate his service and i
appreciate he's got a great military
retirement plan he obviously was an
officer or something or way up there
anyway
and an officer for a lot of years yes
and i appreciate his service and um
but uh and he worked so hard for that
pension that i'm a little bit afraid
he's leaning on it too hard
okay in this plan and and i don't want
it to leave you vulnerable i'm really
not worried about him
i know we talked about that he'll be
fine without me
[Laughter]
well we're talking about monetarily
speaking honey
[Laughter]
but uh yeah that's the this is the way
we plan all the estate planning around
my house is apparently i'm going to die
first which makes me rather worried
sharon has this plan thoroughly but um
but yeah so that that's the thing um
you know i just i want you guys to have
some money and so
uh
if you delay a little bit and knock out
this rehab and then you start some kind
of income to where you can do a couple
of roth iras and at least you start
dumping you know 15 20 000 bucks a year
over there uh at least get something
going because i'd like for you to have a
couple hundred grand or 500 grand in a
paid for house
before one of you passes away
right okay we do have about 180 in a
thrift savings oh i miss that
sorry i know that
we do have that gives me a lot more
comfort then if you want to finish the
rehab
you know if you want to tear into it
that you could do that i guess but the
downside of not following the baby steps
here is you're not building that nist
egg which is your comfort so you've got
that 180 the good news is that in seven
years you know by the time you're in
your early 60s if you don't do anything
with that 180 it's going to be 360.
if you've got it invested in like i tell
you to in the thrift and the c plan the
s and the i and so uh but
uh
yeah so you have 400 grand by the time
you're 60 um and 61 and
you know you'll be okay doing this but
the downside is i don't want you to
extrapolate this too far let's get that
rehab done and then then start investing
because i worry about i always want you
to have more money than just the pension
having that nest egg gives you a lot of
peace yeah more have more options and
well done on uh cash flow in the
renovation so that's a that's a good
step in the journey
jake is in atlanta georgia hi jake
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going great what's up
so i'm 22 just graduated college in may
i'm a pretty good job project engineer
um
pretty much as soon as i graduated
college i needed a new car
um went out a brand new car my dad's in
the car business we kind of talked about
it given everything that's going on by
me a newer used car
um didn't make a ton of sense
um
i drive a long ways to work i'm still
living with my parents uh i intend to
live with them for probably about a year
um if not possible i kind of never want
to have to get an apartment
but you know with living at home with my
parents i drive a long ways to work and
driving into atlanta every day
what so long
um it takes me about an hour um
i'm putting probably 70 miles around
trip every day on my car
yeah and what did you buy
on toyota tacoma
okay so what 30 grand
uh it was 40 but my loan is about 26.
okay
and and i have missed that um
so that was kind of how is it you want
us to help you
well my question was with you know i've
already put i had the truck for about a
little less than three months i already
have 7 000 miles on it
um
you know putting those kind of miles on
a truck um you know my main concern is
that you know given the length of the
loan that i have um
that you know i'm going to get caught in
a cycle where
um you know i'm putting
i'm gonna need to buy a new truck before
i pay off the loan that sort of thing um
so i talked to my dad and we talked
about potentially um doing something
where i traded my truck in every year
and she did a new one
um but then you know at that point i'm
in a cycle where i'm always having a car
payment i never have a car paid off and
i'm always losing a little bit of money
and your question is
well my question is mainly um you know
what do you recommend for somebody who's
in their you know early 20s just out of
college um you know do you think it's a
absolutely terrible idea to keep my
check or should i you know go into
something that's not quite as reliable
uh you know i don't have that better off
you know putting my money somewhere else
i i
perceive from the way you're asking this
question and some of the statements that
you've made that you don't listen to the
show very often or much
no i do listen uh occasionally um i
definitely know your standpoint on uh
buying a new car
okay
and and debt jake and dad that
you know his stance on debt
our stance everybody's okay
okay how much money do you make out of
curiosity
60 000.
we couldn't hear you you're breaking up
how am i 60
did you say 60 000
i did okay
all right let me give you a formula
that will 100 ensure
you're a broke butt 35 year old
okay
follow the plan that you are on
buy new cars and keep buying them and
trading them in and running up miles on
them and you will be a broke butt 30
year old that has supported your
father's company beautifully
and you will be broke
some of the most broke 35 year olds i
meet
have continually traded for new cars
over and over and over and over again in
the first decade of their working life
and they started out with this idiotic
idea that because they graduated from
college they deserve to be 30 000 in
debt on a freaking truck
so no i i'm afraid your dad's not gonna
like dave ramsey uh because i don't like
his advice for his son at all um i would
tell you to sell the truck get you a
cheaper truck move out of your parents
house into a rental close to work
and save your money
and quit investing in things that go
down in value like a rock and then
scratch your head and wonder why you're
broke that's where chevy got that like a
rock
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com survey or text
survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
cart rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christie
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we take your
questions about your life and your money
big week here at ramsey we are launching
christy's book tomorrow official street
date for the book it will ship out it's
already shipped out and it should be at
some of your homes and in all of your
bookstores by tomorrow take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance so the book is on pre-sale
through midnight tonight and that
includes a live stream that she and i
will be doing this thursday evening all
about life balance yeah and you're going
to get the ebook and the audiobook free
if you go ahead and get your copy today
in addition to the hardback book that we
will mail you uh but we're really
excited dave and it's been fun to see
the reviews coming in because we send it
out to our early readers people that
pre-ordered by september 1st got the
e-book and um it's been very interesting
to see there's a common theme in what
people are saying they say this is not
just another time management book this
is not just an and i'm like exactly and
that's that's my
heart behind it and my hope for this
space i love the tagline the guilt-free
guide to life balance man people walk
around all day every day feeling like
they're failing feeling like they never
have enough time they're not good enough
they can't do everything they want to do
and i really try to dig into the issues
below the issues so that we can solve it
there it's not i say all the time it's
not just about the calendar it's about
enjoying the life that the calendar
represents so we're gonna we're gonna
solve this at the root issue and it's
been good to see how that's connecting
with people
it is good to get your work done yeah
and it is good to be noble and diligent
and dutiful
and honorable with your calendar
but then we take that
too far to where then all of those
positive character traits that i just
outlined
can turn into a
a guilt trip they can turn into
i
have now spent the last decade of my
life you look back if you're not careful
and you say stuff like i've spent the
last decade of my life doing what other
people wanted me to do yeah and now i'm
going to do something for me we call
that a mid-life crisis because you
finally catch up and you go screw this i
am not living like this anymore this is
cray-cray and you just blow up yeah
instead of just instead of
incrementally making the adjustments
i'm convinced that a whole lot the one
of the most powerful thing in your book
it's actually a boundaries book
yeah there's a book on how to set
boundaries a book on how to say no yeah
there's so that you can say yes to the
right stuff yeah there's there's a piece
on that too where when we talk about
boundaries in step four i break it down
into five practical actionable steps for
creating balance in your life depending
on what that looks like for you but step
four is all about that about boundaries
but it's interesting because we need to
protect our time and our calendar from
the outside world and all the pushy
people that will tell us you know what
we need to be doing but we also need to
put those things in place to protect us
from ourselves from reacting and the
guilt trips and oh i need to be the hero
and i feel the need to say yes to
everything and people pleasing so so
boundaries work both ways when we look
at it but i'll tell you there's two
pieces of this um there's two pieces to
this book that i think have hit a nerve
that are different than what i've seen
out there on time management one
is the idea of seasons
and how when i talk about what doing the
right things it's at the right time so
in the season you're in for example
everyone listening to this show is
probably familiar with the baby steps if
you're in baby step two then you're
number one
priority
financially at least
is to get out of debt get out of debt
get out of debt and so when you're
taking two and three
jobs to get a bigger shovel that's
what's right right now it doesn't mean
you're gonna do that forever this is
what's right in this season and so i
don't want to be a workaholic
i doubt that's going to be your problem
but it gives permit it gives people
permission
to do the right things at the right time
to say hey what's with priority for us
either financially or with our calendar
is this thing right here it could be a
busy season at work i'm in a really busy
season right now at work and that's
what's right right now
and so there's an aspect of seasons the
other piece of it and dave you and i
have talked about this um i don't think
we talk enough about
um how being present
affects our ability to feel balanced
because it doesn't matter if you create
the most perfect schedule in the world
if you're not present for it you miss it
so if you're spending all of your days
at work thinking about your kids and
then you go home with your kids and
you're thinking about work well of
course you always feel guilty because
you're always focused on where you're
not i'll tell you the worst one i ever
did okay and i did i caught myself doing
this the third time and i never did it
again okay planning the next vacation
while on
vacation yeah this is so fun let's do
that it's not being present
i'm sitting on my laptop planning the
next vacation
from my vacation that's just dumber in a
rock i've done that you just got so
excited about that vacation you're like
let's do this again well that that could
be what caused it but yeah
find another place yeah it feels like
this but uh yeah but i'm i'm you know i
got time with my hands i plan the next
thing that's the way my brain works and
yeah but that's just that's not being
present well it's interesting because i
think we are so used to input and we
have this from our phone we have a
device in our pocket that screams our
name 24 hours a day but we're so used to
this input we're constantly having input
in our brains we don't know how to be
still
we don't know how to be silent we don't
know how to walk in an elevator and just
stare at the doors
everybody reaches for their phone
and so just there's an aspect of this of
learning how to be present in the moment
that you're in even if what you're doing
is mundane you know what's fascinating
dave research from harvard shows
that the more present you are research
shows it has a direct correlation and
causation with happiness you're actually
happier when you're present in the
moments i want to help people be where
you're feeling even if it's a negative
moment even if it's a negative moment
isn't that fascinating though
when you bring your mind back to your
body
even if what you're doing is mundane
research shows you're happier it turns
out our mind was designed to be in our
body and doing what our body is doing
and so gosh in our world when you're
scrolling social media and your mind is
wandering 100 miles an hour that's a
gift to bring it back to the present and
actually enjoy a moment you're in while
you're in it what a concept it's a hard
thing to do in the world we live in well
because we've got this power
to
uh teleport ourselves
i mean if you think back if you went
back um
100 years 200 years
and you took your phone with you
and it would do then what it does now
people would think that you were like a
sorcerer yeah
i mean it's like a little magic wand
thing
you could just touch a button and stuff
would be delivered to your front porch
and stuff you know
and you know i mean people you could you
can
and people would talk on it yes
oh my can you imagine you'd be you'd be
burned at the stake for being a witch
you know i mean you jolly you think
about it because it's magic i heard one
guy say it's like it's like having magic
and you have to be careful with magic
yeah it's uh it can become a spiritual
problem
and i think it has screens have become
that for a lot of people well and i
don't i don't hate phones or technology
or social media yeah but people could
put in that category like oh you just no
it's not that but i think that if we're
going to live in a world where you have
a device in your pocket screaming your
name 24 hours a day and there's
fascinating research i actually cite in
the book on the psychology of screens
notifications everything about how we
interact with our phone if we're gonna
have that we're gonna have to have a
plan to be able to actually enjoy our
life if not we're gonna spend our whole
life knowing what everyone else is doing
and completely miss our own and i want
to help people take their time back and
take their attention back and actually
enjoy their own life the book is take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance today is the last day that
you can buy it on pre-sale which
includes our live stream event this
coming thursday night the e-book and the
audiobook all at ramseysolutions.com
be sure you hit up the website today and
get the deal that's how it works this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host at triple eight eight two five
five two two five kelsey is in seattle
washington hi kelsey how are you
hi dave hi christie i'm great how are
you better than we deserve how can we
help
um
unrelated to my question i hope to be
there in about 12 months to do my debt
free stream so
fingers crossed for that
i did something crazy and moved back
home with my parents so i'll be i'll be
ready to go to nashville in a year cool
um so i have a question about long-term
insurance you had a call recently from a
gentleman in washington state as well
and i know you're not super familiar
with the new long-term care tax for
washington state
but
i'm 36 years old single no children
there's a deadline for me to purchase
alternative long-term care
before
this goes into effect next year
so i'm not familiar with life insurance
or long-term care
i went on xander's website it says that
they don't have anything available due
to insurance companies in my state
withdrawing their products until
november
i'm i'm just kind of stuck
yeah
okay i um
it's not life insurance you don't want
anything to do with life insurance on
this subject that's a completely
different subject do not put them
together
okay because bundling long-term care and
life insurance together is what some of
the industry is doing and it is it's a
really crummy horribly priced product so
stay away from that stuff what you need
to do is get the minimum
method the cheapest possible method for
you to check this box
so it comes down to is the tax going to
be cheaper
or buying a cheap policy going to be
cheaper
and i suspect since the entire freaking
state is facing this
communist movement in your state
um that
that somebody is bringing a capitalistic
uh solution to the table to
provide some kind of inexpensive
long-term care
some cheap but policy that does a
horrible job but doesn't cost much and
it costs less than the tax because
you're 36 and you don't even need it
right
that's what i'm guessing it's gonna
yeah it's gonna be 0.58
payroll tax but the benefit is only up
to 36 500. i don't care what the benefit
is you're thirty six years like a lot
yeah i don't care what the benefit is
you're 36 year old the chances of you
using this before 60 are less than two
percent
so it's just it's not relevant it's a
dumb butt law by communists i mean it
really is it's ridiculous i hope i'm
being real clear to you people in in the
government and washington state how much
how lowly i think of you
but um
but anyway the yeah yeah
it's ridiculous so anyway what you've
got to do is figure out what's the least
expensive thing now is the point what do
you make a year
uh 75 000.
and it's uh half of a percent so it's
350 bucks a year is the tax
right i calculated like four or 35-ish
okay yeah 400 400 bucks a year i doubt
you can buy a policy that cheap you're
probably just paying the tax
but i'll give you a way to shop i'm able
to get out of it do what
what if i'm not able to get out of the
long-term care that i'm paying taxes for
later if i decided to get something else
you don't
need to worry about that until 60.
okay
so i'm not going to worry about it the
chances that this law is in place
exactly this way and that you are still
in washington state both are almost zero
something will have changed
i mean we're talking 25 years
okay so i'm not
you know i i would pay the 400. now if
you want to check and see if there's any
cheaper way
you can just go to an independent
insurance broker and you can check on
one of our insurance elps
probably the p and c guys the guys that
do car insurance and homeowners
insurance on our website
some of our ramsey trusted guys and gals
they may be able to write you a policy
if they're in washington state they will
be able to access whoever is trying to
do something for you people that
basically this is a tax
it's just a tax that's all it is it's
one more tax they put on you
and um
that's what it comes down to because
again you're not getting anything for it
a huge benefit and you don't even need
the coverage it's like it's like they're
gonna tax you for not buying car
insurance
and you don't have a car
okay for everyone listening right now
that is going what are you talking about
like i am right now what is going on in
in washington they're forcing people to
pass a law that says if you don't buy
long-term care insurance nursing home
insurance that they're going to charge
you a penalty at any age apparently okay
okay so so okay
so now you realize i'm not being i'm not
being over melodramatic when i'm stating
that they're communist you're not okay
so for for clarity purposes for everyone
else across the united states at what
age do people need to consider long-term
care 60 60 okay the chances of you using
a policy are going into a nursing home
yes or needing in-home care permanently
uh before 60 are less than three percent
but at 60 you start to look at this at
60 at 60 you need to get it unless you
it is a great thing to buy long-term
care insurance then
because between 60 and 70 the chances of
using it go up exponentially right
obviously the older you get um and
uh the normal thing that happens in your
60s or 70s
is say a typical couple married
75 of the ladies outlive their husbands
and so dad goes into the nursing home
uh they have 300 000 saved he uses it up
on nursing home bills and dies
mom's penniless
so you don't do that you buy a long-term
care insurance policy in your 60s early
60s so that it covers that 300 grand so
mom still has the 300 grand after his
nursing home visit before he dies is
there a window
where it's too late to get long-term
care insurance yeah because it's based
on your age and your health okay and so
there's a point in which they'll say you
can't i don't know i don't think you can
get it at 80. yeah i don't think you can
get it at 70 whatever i don't know what
the number is but and i know you can't
get it if you have tremendous illness
okay if you've been diagnosed with uh
uh
dementia yeah you know alzheimer's
it's too late too late yeah your house
already burned you can't buy fire
insurance yeah so uh that's the problem
so but that and that's what scares
everybody so they want to run out and
buy it early and all that kind of stuff
and we want to make sure that uh that
the elderly are taken care of and here's
the super bad thing about washington
state okay they're acting like that
these people aren't taken care of
there's a whole program called medicaid
which is welfare right but medicaid
nursing home is paid for it's for that
right for the pope for the poor and so
if you don't have any money or have any
insurance
welfare will pay for your nursing home
i don't recommend that as a plan
right but this idea that somehow we need
to tax a 36 year old in washington state
on her 70 000 income while she's trying
to build her life to provide for this
when the federal government already has
the plan in place is just more socialism
communism
you know
and um
it's from the people right in the center
of the state called seattle that's where
it's coming from the rest of them have
brains
and it's just unbelievable i mean it's
it's a it's basically a
well that's helpful i appreciate the
explanation because i'm thinking even
for my generation so i'm 38 i don't need
it but it does help me think in terms of
my parents my in-laws so so my
generation that might be thinking hey is
this something to look into or to talk
to your parents about because you have
to have you have to have the long-term
care talk yeah and you need to get and
because you know the chances of spending
some time in a nursing home are very
high and it's usually not that long most
people don't stand there two years or
something max and so it's typically a
you know three four hundred thousand
dollar max out-of-pocket situation and
so if you've got 10 million dollars you
can self-insure through it yes if you're
a baby-step millionaire now
and you look up 15 years from now and
you got 10 million dollars uh you could
self-insure through it mom will still be
fine right you know
and besides that you pay for in-home
care
uh private care right
high quality right right personal butler
you know
kind of thing and you got 10 million
dollars shut up so but that's because
you built that's one of the advantages
of building wealth and being able to
self-insure through some of these things
but it's the you know the very poor
medicaid's got welfare the very rich can
do it for themselves people that are on
baby steps plans but the ones in the
middle need long-term care insurance
when they get to be 60. that's good
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author tomorrow
her new book launches take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance today is the last day you can
get the pre-sale items over fifty
dollars worth of stuff at
ramseysolutions.com and sign up for our
live stream take back your time she and
i are doing this coming thursday night
it'll all be part of that package at
ramseysolutions.com in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
josh and jillian are with us hey guys
how are you we're doing great welcome
welcome where do you guys live grand
rapids michigan well welcome to
nashville and how much debt have you
paid off about 90 000. all right awesome
how long did that take uh
six years in like two months very good
and your range of income during that
time uh just under 30 to between 80 and
90. good nice bump okay what do you guys
do for a living um i work with uh
computer uh cad programming for
tooling guys and she does cleaning all
right very good actually runs her own
business so she's uh she was looking
forward to meeting christy wright
awesome all right good very good so what
kind of debt was this 90 000
our home you paid off your ass
looking at weirdos yeah i love it very
cool when you're young how old are you
guys uh 38 and 36. all right not even 40
in a paid for house in grand rapids
michigan what's the house worth about
270.
it's all yours yeah how many of your
friends haven't paid for house not many
games
none just us
we did it
i like it good for you guys you're weird
awesomeness that is already fun what
started your story how'd this whole
thing get started for you well i'd heard
of dave ramsey when i was going to a
college age group at our church and we
went through i didn't even pay attention
to what it was so it's something debt
free sounds very college
it was it was good because i did make it
through college debt-free and you know
had the principles moving forward with
buying the home but it really got
kick-started when we bought our first
home
and it's kind of the first
big
debt that we had we were blessed not to
have college debt we had family that
took care of that so it was kind of
shocking to us to have this
big collection oh god and the family on
the way so we were like all right uh
we're
under this debt let's get it done yeah
and then we uh actually we're on such a
tight budget we had to get your book
from the library i like it so we we
rented it basically we went through the
dave ramsey dave yeah y'all are
uncomfortable with that from the get-go
which is which is weird
yeah and awesome like yeah the fact that
you even saw it like that and thought we
got to get rid of this yeah initially
that's amazing yeah and then was that
your family your upbringing what yeah
both of our family were pretty much on
that same that instilled those
principles on us about trying to not be
in debt and you know getting a mortgage
you can afford not you know paying for
our cars outright basically is what we
were kind of raised with and so it's
like grand rapids community man i know
it was grandma's wisdom
dutch reform movement man it's a big
deal
i love it i love it i've had a i've had
a heart connection to grand rapids for
30 years it's amazing it's strong there
it's in the water yeah very good you
guys way to go man congratulations
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world and you're not even 40. oh
my goodness it's a relief it's hard to
believe even so it feels like
we could do anything yeah that's awesome
what's the secret you guys have done
something that very few people have done
what would you say is the secret to not
just getting debt free but paying off
your house
for me it was definitely don't let
anything that gets you down or bumps
that get in the way
i
make you think it's impossible we had
several bumps along the way we have five
pregnancies and adoption we started a
business we actually moved houses and
renovated one so i mean there's a lot of
different things
cars died in the six years and
everything was a setback you know
um but we got back up and said we're
doing it for our kids we're doing it for
our future and we're doing it so we can
be generous and outrageously generous in
the future so and i think recognizing
too all those little bumps we were able
to pay in cash for them so even though
it felt like oh darn that was one extra
house payment that we're not able to do
he would always remind me like yeah but
we're still winning we're paying in cash
for this yeah so recognizing the little
victories is important too yeah you're
not you're not going backwards no you
just slowed your forward exactly yeah
that's a good perspective yeah because
uh you can lose hope if you just if
everything slows down too much you can't
you don't feel like you're going to get
there you don't feel like you got
traction but as long as you're moving in
the right direction even if it's a small
step and a few of the months are a
little slow because something else comes
up you just keep going just keep pushing
ahead that's very strong yeah yeah and
it sometimes it felt like the hits just
kept coming but again we just tried to
have that perspective of this is for our
children this is a legacy it's something
that's passed to us and it's important
to pass on so
you make a good point that any of those
setbacks became kind of inconveniences
but you had the cash to cover them so
many people that are you know up to
their eyeballs in debt they're living
paycheck to paycheck when they get a
setback it becomes an emergency and
stressful and anxiety and you guys were
able to pay for them that in itself is
such a gift that you guys worked hard
because you set yourself up that way
yeah yeah and we had to be really
intentional about getting our income up
um which is why it took us a bit because
we started a small business and we did
it with cash and we grew it slowly but
something that kind of surprised me was
like our house has paid off oh we still
have that income coming in
we get to keep this money yeah if it
went towards paying the house that we're
kind of like wait a minute
yeah this might work out yeah
who thought yeah
way to go guys i'm so proud of you thank
you and how does it feel to be free just
amazing yeah it's just amazing i feel so
proud for my kids actually how many kids
four of them four boys four all right
four boys all under seven whoa
that's why we're here without them
wow i get it you've earned a vacation in
so many ways that's right okay so
outside of the two of you who are your
biggest cheerleaders people cheering you
on
our biggest cheerleader is probably my
sister she's the one that i would call
when i was feeling down but ironically
she was real skeptical of dave at the
beginning
and we just she just watched us and i
think she had some other exposure to
dave and she actually went through your
fine she's a financial coach now so wow
she was like uh i don't know what you
guys are listening to
that's not how the world works
she became our biggest cheerleader
really yeah
yeah that's fun so we brought her all
the way into the fold yeah yeah
definitely all right she's joined the
pole yeah
i love it way to go guys way to go i'm
so proud of you thank you what a
wonderful thing you've done you've got
to feel accomplished yeah you got to
feel powerful yeah it feels great very
cool not even 40 years old in a paid for
house worth almost 300
000
very cool we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's what you've done
it's changed your legacy for those boys
and all the generations after you and
the things you're going to be able to do
with generosity you're going to be
amazing and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away get
somebody started on their journey
they've been inspired by watching you
probably and you maybe didn't even
realize it so that'll be there uh in
your hands for you to work with as well
so good job josh and jillian grand
rapids michigan 90 000
paid off that's their house and
everything took them six years and two
months making 30 up to 90. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one we're done free
out there in the wild folks how many 40
year olds do you meet with a paid for
300 000 house making under 100 000.
none
that's a that's a beautiful thing
paid for house i mean we're seeing it
again and again and again it's just it's
mind-blowing but also it's really cool
to hear these stories because the more
common they are the more people are
going to hear this and go oh it's
possible and not only that if they can
do it i can do it it gives them that
hope yeah hey maybe you could do
something different i love how uh how he
said uh that's not the way the world
works it's like yeah the world is broke
if you listen to that you're gonna stay
broke you can do it differently and they
did well that's why we call them weird
yeah because um 78 of americans live
paycheck to paycheck
so just being in control is weird
uh getting out of debt and paying off
your house by the time you're 40 oh
you're just a freak
i love it it's awesome the best kind of
freak the best the kind of freaks we
love yeah
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
her new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance comes
out tomorrow the pre-sale specials are
up today if you want the deal go to
ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or you pick the wrong color they'll
remake your blinds for free free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best possible deal
today's question comes from adam in
alabama
my wife and i have two sides to our
business one is catering and the other
is full-service restaurant we started
these businesses three years ago and
they are debt free with covid still
prevalent we have taken a significant
hit with low sales supply chain issues
and staffing problems
my wife ties her identity and self-worth
to the success of this business but i
would be glad to close it down she wants
to take a loan to keep us afloat and i'm
not in agreement with this plan
should i hold on and struggle and even
go into debt i know the answer is no but
how can i do it when my spouse is
against me
and afraid of the future
well there's a lot going on here um
a lot i mean the the obvious is you and
your spouse need to get on the same page
regardless of what you do and you know
adam that we're we're never going to
tell you to take out a loan
um
but even if you don't take out a loan
and even regardless of what path you
take with the business you still need to
get on the same page with your spouse
you and your wife need to get on some
page of the vision
get to the root of what her fears are
what she's struggling with and so on the
other thing is just from a business
standpoint i can't help but
uh want to dig into that and go okay
what's the real problem yeah you may be
having some struggles and yes some of it
is coveted but is there a way to say
okay we're gonna
maybe shut down the restaurant and go
all in on catering or maybe we're going
to
downsize a little bit scale back to
where because we have staffing issues
we're going to do just the pieces that
we can do ourselves or you know i just i
like to problem solve but sometimes when
you're just
sad or scared or overwhelmed
uh it it feels bigger than it is it
feels more impossible than it is
actually put that on instagram today
you know
sometimes when you're overwhelmed things
just feel
bigger scarier and more impossible than
they actually are so i wonder if some of
these are not
very fixable problems adam that if you
could fix these problems
the business could do better the sales
would improve you don't have to take out
a loan obviously which we're not going
to tell you to do and
you and your spouse can get on the same
page for the vision um
you know and obviously her identity
doesn't need to be attached to it but as
a business owner you know this dave like
you you can't totally emotionally
separate yourself from the success of
the business because it is your baby
there's an aspect of it that's that's
healthy and then you don't want it to be
well my sole source of identity is here
we know that so
it's a lot it's a lot's going on i feel
like in this question yeah it's
unhealthy
to not tie some of your identity and
some of your
uh self-worth to your business because
you're pouring yourself
into it
and to completely detach from that would
make you a psychopath yeah you care and
so you actually care about it and it's
it's my thing it's like it's something i
poured a lot into so it'd be unhealthy
to do that what i don't like hearing is
she ties her identity and self-worth to
the success
of the business so what you have to do
is you have to back yourself up and say
okay
there are some things in this that i can
control
for those things i'm going to tie my
some of my self-worth
and some of my identity to it and i'm
gonna get my butt in gear and i'm gonna
push some stuff around and make it
happen because i care right
uh then there's things you can't control
you can't make people
come to work
in the restaurant business right now
when they're being paid to sit at home
by the stupid federal government
everywhere you go high-end low-end
restaurants and anything that service
industry is struggling with labor
shortage because they're sitting at home
until the federal government stops that
i mean that's just that's not something
you'd caused so i'm not gonna if i'm you
i'm not gonna go oh i did something
wrong i feel bad about me
i can't get labor and so we have to
scale this back to the labor that i can
get which is me and thee right and um
and whatever else i mean
however many kids we had
whatever we're we're all going to be in
here working but i can't make anybody
else work yeah um and i can't make
a supply chain stuff be right right i
can't make i mean we're fighting
scratching with these paper people
there's a paper shortage now get these
books out
your books are in coleman's bookshare
and we got books scheduled for january
i'm buying paper form now
because i know that we got a supply
chain problem so but i can't say oh
there's a paper shortage and so
i feel bad about me
no i feel like there's a paper shortage
right
i don't need to feel bad nothing had to
do with it my identity's not tired of
that so
it gets real cliche but sometimes pieces
of something have to die for something
to grow or even the whole thing dies for
something to grow back where there's
this much manure there's plenty of
opportunity to grow
that's for sure and we've had the same
thing around here kiddo i mean we've
been pivoting so much i feel like i'm
just chasing a dog chasing its tail uh
changing stuff and moving things around
how we deliver products and you know
what a book tour used to look like to
what it looks like today there's not one
now we do it all virtual
because the people in new york have lost
their ever-loving minds in the media
world uh what it you know they want us
to
like put our first born in a vault or
something just to go see them and it's
just like you people are nuts forget it
and so no you're not going to extract my
dna for me to come into your studio
you've lost your dad gum mines so we
have to we have to adjust and pivot the
whole thing and so um
uh uh
i think that this is god whispering to
your wife
to get this business
in its proper perspective within her
psyche
because it's gonna kill her if it
succeeds
and and it owns her
it'll ride her into the grave yeah if it
fails and it owns her it'll ride her
into the grave so she's got to get back
on top of it and start owning it there's
nothing wrong we're confirming that you
should care deeply we're confirming that
it should
hurt your feelings that you that your
business that you built is failing to do
to nothing that you did wrong
i mean you got government interference
you've got economic interference labor
shortages and supply chain shortages you
did nothing wrong
it hurts your feelings and you grieve
that as deloney would say yeah
and you know all of that is is normal
but i think this is the opportunity to
not to take out a loan but instead to
decide who owns what there's a business
on her she own it
and if she owns it she can close part of
it
i own this
i don't want to close any of it it's
true that gum hard to open but i will
close it and then i'll still be here
i'll still be here
and i'll still be whole
and i'll i'll be sad yeah but um but i
you know if we shut down something that
i love here
because it doesn't work anymore i'll be
sad i've done it before i've closed down
the whole uh business units here that
that just didn't work and i had invested
millions of dollars and a lot of my
emotion into and it hurts
but i'm also still here yeah because i
own it it doesn't own me and really i
think that's the core atom of what you
all got to do it's not about do i go
along with my spouse the answer is no
you don't go along with your spouse
because your spouse is not functioning
well here is what you're saying yeah and
i like how you made that distinction too
of you're going to control what you can
control and we always say this but
control which you can control what does
that look like in light of the problems
you're facing what you can do what you
can fix what is right for you given
everything you're coming up against and
those things that you can't control you
can't you let those go and you separate
your identity and your self-worth from
all these outside challenges that have
nothing to do with you that you didn't
do
and i just think that's a really helpful
distinction yeah i i cannot control what
the biden administration does they may
close me down they may put me out of
business i can't control it i can't
control what they do the only thing i
can control is what i can control yeah
and that's me yeah and whether i
whether i stand whether i stand on
principle whether i'm a person of
integrity uh and whether i've done the
best i can do with what was in front of
me and then sometimes
it still doesn't work yeah
yep and out of that is always born out
of those ashes as a phoenix always rises
up
and it's very cliche but there's a
reason for those cliches is it happens
happens all the time the death of a
relationship is the birth of something
new the death of
of a business is the birth of a new idea
out of those ashes it happens all the
time
if you own it
instead of it owning you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five christy wright
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is launch
week for her new book take back your
time
the guilt-free guide
to life balance
it's only twenty dollars and today is
the last day
tomorrow's launch day
today's the last day if you buy you get
the audiobook free the e-book free
an accent access to our live event that
is this coming thursday night for free
all of this is almost an extra hundred
dollars worth of value highly suggest
you do all of that if you want to learn
something about life balance christy and
i are going to help you do that
especially christy with this new book it
is uh it's a beautiful book it is a
wonderful thesis it's the life-changing
transformational kinds of material here
and we are excited that it is coming out
on the ramsey brand uh the ramsey press
label and uh
it it's gonna be fun it's gonna be good
yeah it's been fun to see the reviews
come in and uh it's one of those things
that and you talk about this all the
time dave we um
you know you intersect with the podcast
we see people all the time on the debt
free stage they listen to the podcast
change their life you read a book
one maybe one takeaway or one concept
one principle one step
changes how you live your life which has
a direct ripple effect forever so that's
that's the heart behind this is to help
people take their time back truly
literally
and uh and so they can spend their life
on what's most important to them take
back your time at
ramseysolutions.com you can get it there
at 20 bucks if you order it today we
will ship it today and you can download
the ebook the audiobook and everything
uh within 24 hours and you'll be able to
watch us on the live stream on thursday
night we've got about 21 seats left here
in the studio if you want to join us in
the ramsey solutions headquarters we're
going to have a small about 200 250
person studio audience
for the event on thursday night and we
can get a few of you in if you want to i
just put again ramseysolutions.com
time aaron is with us aaron is in
evansville indiana hi erin how are you
i'm talking to dave and christy so i'm
fantastic
what's up kiddo
hey i have a business budgeting question
for you guys today
i launched my business on july 15th of
this year
how many months should it take to have a
set budget
after going through the baby steps and
my own personal life
this unknown business budget at about
two months and feels very uncomfortable
to me okay what's your business
i am a crop insurance agent and i opened
up my own agency cool okay awesome
well because you've experienced this on
the personal side then you know it can
take a few months to
start to see the rhythms and that type
of thing the only thing is on on the
personal side you have a track record of
your bank statements to look at and go
hey we spend about this much on
groceries or we spend this about this
much on electricity that type of thing
because this business is so new erin
a lot of that's unknown so you're going
to set a budget and these are
projections that are going to
incrementally get more accurate month
over month
however
it's still a projection really what i
mean really within your first year now
you're going to have a more accurate
idea in
three months or four months than you did
on your first month it's going to get
hopefully more accurate but it is going
to take a little bit more time because
this business is so new you're going to
see what what seasonality looks like in
your business and you're going to start
to see the trends obviously that will
reflect marketing or what's going on in
the world uh what what the trends are in
your industry that type of thing so just
know that similar to the personal side
of budgeting
it can take some time in fact it can
take more time because it's so new
because you don't have these
bank statements to refer to like you do
on the personal side so it's a
projection though it's a goal you're
still budgeting every step of the way
just know that it might take a little
bit more time to get more accurate dave
how do you have a rule of thumb that you
advise people when you're talking about
budgeting and it's a new business
especially in the first year
i i i think you're right i think it's
incremental the the longer you've been
in business the more accurate your
budget's going to be
we launched a new product here we don't
know what it's going to do but we've got
your planner coming out this year and
it's what the sixth year or fourth year
or what is it fourth or fifth fourth or
fifth year of putting out the christy
wright planner which is a calendar that
sells for forty nine dollars it's out
right now as a matter of fact and so we
can predict the sales on that based on
those the trend lines right every year
has gotten better we've sold more every
year right uh substantially more every
year but we can trendline that out and
so we've got something but the first
year it was a guest that was i guess it
was a total not even a budget it's just
a guess
and so that's kind of what you're doing
right now you're guessing it's hopefully
an educated guess and actually our first
year budgeting on that planner was not
that far off we hit it pretty close but
it was a guess and you know you could do
a whole lot more or a whole lot less
than you thought you were gonna do and
then you make adjustments from there and
then you say okay what are the what is
that she said the seasonality to this as
you go along but what i do want you to
do to know is two things one is
you should be upset
the less accurate is the longer you've
been doing it if you've been doing this
10 years and your budget's still like an
unknown and you're freaked out about it
you're not this something's wrong okay
but if you've been doing it 10 months
you're just now kind of getting in the
saddle but every month
you should be
getting a little bit more accurate a
little better and then certainly after
you've gone through a few years of it
and you say oh well fall is always a big
time spring is not whatever it is i
don't
i suspect the crop insurance thing might
be tied to that you know yeah be tied
something to seasonality i suspect
you're going to have some
some times that are big and sometimes
that aren't but you're going to see that
and you're going to build that into your
business model
john is with us in minneapolis hey john
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and chris thanks for taking my
call sure
so
i have a question uh regarding a free
will gift and where that might work in
the baby steps so
from the last thing i was saying right
now we were gifted um a
chunk of money from my parents for a
down payment on our home
uh my parents are extremely generous
with the time and their money and we
don't want to appear ungrateful
quite the contrary we want to reward
them for their generosity
and in our short baby step journey we've
experienced what it's like to be
debt-free
and although this gift is not strictly a
debt
we do feel like it's something that
separates us from being financially free
so
what
what i thought it was a gift
why did you declare it alone what right
do you have to declare it alone
well
it's something that from time to time
has been has been brought up in
conversation
and i don't think it's been brought up
after the fact with any malice from my
parents but it is something that is
still
talked about in what way so they hold it
over your head
no no no they don't hold it over our
head at all no
so what they brought it up and said one
time we gave you 40 grand so you owe us
i mean i don't understand
was it a gift or not
it was a good gift
i think your wife needs to let this go
it's a gift
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
okay if you guys want some help in
different areas of your life get your
pencil ready here's what we're doing
this thursday night
we have a live stream from ramsey
solutions headquarters
christy wright and i on her new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance i will open up the live
stream and christy will do the majority
of the teaching obviously it's her
material and her
new book that comes out tomorrow this
coming saturday and if you want to be in
the live studio audience we have about
20 or 18 or 14 or whatever it is right
now tickets left they're free and you
can come and are they free to come in
the audience if you use the promo code
time and you get your book signed when
you're here so come join us yeah there's
a few tickets left if you want to come
and be part of the studio audience
thursday night at dave
ramseysolutions.com time then on
saturday we are doing a financial peace
accelerated event here
and rachel george camel john deloney and
i are teaching the entire financial
peace university
in one day
all nine lessons
long day
for the audience and for the speakers
and uh we're gonna get the whole thing
in and it is here in our lobby and i
think there's about five tickets left to
that and i think there's a charge for
that so ramsay solutions.com and you get
the whole financial peace university
ramsey ramsey plus thing is all every
dollar is all tied into that it's all
one package and you can come and be in
the because we're doing a video shoot to
reshoot some of the lessons and uh is
what we're doing and so but again i
think we've got about three or four
hundred tickets for that it might be
sold out but it's right at it somewhere
right around there check
ramseysolutions.com for that then
on september
the 28th
christy and george campbell and i will
be doing an event to help you set your
life and your money up to go win called
game plan
we want to put you in place for your
game plan this is a completely free live
stream
again there is a few tickets for the
live studio audience same exact venue
and so we'll limit that to 300 or so
tickets max something like that and uh
because we've got camera crews and
everything else in there to shoot the
live stream with and game plan is all
about helping you get a game plan
breathing room in your time breathing
room and your money what it takes to
have a game plan what it takes for you
to win
winning is an intentional act and it
requires a game plan if you're going to
win the super bowl you need a game plan
if you're going to win your career you
need a game plan if you're going to win
your life and your money you need a game
plan
that is september the 28th that is a
free live stream and uh you can text
game plan to 33 789 all one word and uh
you don't have to live a life that's
normal we'll show you how to have a game
plan and again that's a free live stream
september the 28th christy wright george
campbell and me text one word game plan
two three three
seven eight nine so three live streams
in the next week or two
a lot of stuff going on around here a
lot of cameras and camera crews and
stuff moving around uh it's turned to
turn this place into a dead gun
production facility but uh hey let's do
it man whatever it takes to win let's go
christian is with us in virginia beach
virginia hi christian how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so
i recently um i'm in the
military in the navy and um i'm
basically
trying to have a date on when i'll
projected to rotate out of the military
into the civilian world
and i just wanted to know
what would be
a good number to have in my savings
account
god forbid i couldn't find a job
after being so used to such a i've never
transitioned from an actual career to
another one yeah how old are you i don't
necessarily know 24. when will you
transition out
potentially in 2026.
okay well we got some time to plan
that's what i was thinking too um i
i've never
so i my idea was i would like probably
i don't know 85 000 or 100 000 in my
savings but i mean that just seems like
such an unrealistic number
having never had more than 20 000 in my
savings before yeah what do you make
right now probably about 48 000. good
for you well thank you for your service
and i think it depends christie on
everything on what he lands in yeah and
how quickly lands well and that and i
just i think you're playing that
yeah like i i think you'll be fine
obviously if you have 80 000 christian
but i don't think you have to have 80
000 to be able to make that transition
i think you could make it on less i
think there's probably you know in your
mind that that's a number that gives you
peace of mind which is fine and i think
you can you can save between now and
then but you got some time
and i think you would be just fine on
less especially if you spend the next
three years not just saving money but
thinking about what you want to do
working on those contacts like ken
coleman talks about we can we can give
you a copy of king coleman's new book
christian where he talks about getting
clear what you want to do and getting
connected with the people that are doing
it what's cool is you're thinking so far
in advance
you can start making some of those
connections and even getting clear on it
between now and then where by the time
that you're out you're not starting from
scratch then which is going to give you
a huge head start where you won't even
need that much of a savings if any to be
able to transition to that job
now the other variable in this equation
is your new job and how quick it lands
okay
so let's let's play pretend
let's you make 48 you said right yeah
let's pretend that your new job makes
148
and it starts the day after you rotate
out of the military
how much money do you need in savings
none
right
you're right
i mean it'd be nice to have some but in
order to survive you just got a hundred
thousand dollar a year raise i think you
can struggle through it you know
so it has to do with what how quickly
you have landed something and so you
land that you you plan that soft landing
and you start working it hard a year out
and you start landing into that career
and figuring out what you've got to do
to tool up to get to to get that deal
and you know it's probably going to be a
raise
and you're probably if you if you set it
up right you're going to join the next
week after you leave the military and
you don't you don't need any savings now
the other end of the coin is it takes
you 10 years to get employed well you
would have needed a million dollars in
right
which is absurd
yeah
it is so you're not going to take that
long so the way to lower this need or to
scratch this itch is not the size of the
savings account it is the surety of the
landing pad
and the place you're going to be and
that's what i would work on so i'd start
reading everything ken coleman writes
hold on i'll have kelly's son send you a
copy of his first book the proximity
principle and then you can go buy from
paycheck to purpose it comes out in
november it's on pre-sale right now
and
go to the ken coleman website
kingcoleman.com
start listening to a show on career and
you know you got plenty of time to
figure out your purpose
and plug into it and have a good soft
landing and the more sure that is and
the better that is the less money and
savings you'll need that's the part of
the formula that that was missing
all right up next can be art in phoenix
hey art how are you
art there hey art art's gone no art
didn't make it okay well let's
uh sorry art try something else here
what did i do maybe maybe i'm gonna
start up i don't think i did lindsey is
in charleston hi lindsay how are you
hi dave how are you
good what's up
well i'm going to give you a quick
background and then thank you in advance
for helping me with this i am 58 years
old my husband's 69.
we didn't follow any principles because
we were never taught to until just a few
years ago
when we found you and where we are today
we have
absolutely no debt except a mortgage
that has 180 000 dollars
we have six months savings
we have about 600 000 in our retirement
way to go
yeah
thank you um thanks to you um and my
question is we have a beautiful 130 year
old house that we've completely
renovated over the last
20 years out in the country
um we did put it on the market because
we thought that it's the best time to
sell while the market's good and the
only reason we're going to do that
is because my husband's getting older
and feels like he's not going to be able
to keep up this 15 acres without help
at some point and to secure our
retirement all right i tell you what you
hang on we come back for this break i'll
give you a quick answer to that i don't
want to rush it with 10 seconds left
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today lindsay is in charleston
south carolina they've got a home
that is a beautiful old home on 15 acres
outside of charleston south carolina her
husband's 69 she's 58
or they're debt free except for that
they've done a really really good job
but the maintenance of the uh beautiful
old home is wearing thin on him along
with the 15 acres and they're talking
about selling it is that a fair summary
of what you told me so far
lindsay did i push the button let me try
lindsay there you are
hey is that a fair summary of what i
said of what you told me so far
yes i think so okay so what's your
question
my question is to secure our retirement
is that going to be the right thing to
do we made every mistake that you've
ever mentioned
um
starting the baby steps so we did not
know about you or did not even make any
plans until about five years ago my
income
went up tremendously
so we really just started planning and
paying off everything in retirement five
years ago but my concern is
we won't be ready
when i'm ready to retire
my husband retired a little early
and
we know an old house as nice as it is
going to continue to need
um constant maintenance of some kind so
we'll show you let me let me see if i
can read your mail
okay sure
the dream that this house represented
has died and it's hard to let it go
absolutely it was cute and fun and had
some acreage and has a lot of character
and it's a historic cool baby
but the reality is it's a pain in the
butt
well it's only a pain when when it's a
pain
so i just sold my i just sold my home
and i'm going through the exact same
emotions i built this big beautiful home
up on the side of a hill i lived there
12 14 years and i had an absolute blast
in the home it is an amazing property
but it got to where just keeping the
freaking light bulbs changed was too
much trouble
and so we just decided a new adventure
was at hand we sold it and now i'm kind
of grieving moving off the side of that
beautiful mountain but i'm also needing
to move because it's the next season in
my life the season has changed and i
have to grieve the dream that is gone
and uh enjoy the memories of the past
that was there and move on to the next
chapter which is wisdom
and uh it's part of my adventure and
it's it's a wonderful adventure and so
you might enjoy having some new
appliances in a new house after living
in there uh because they don't build
them like they used to
thank god
yeah it's true of houses and cars
think about what that makes possible
lindsay like when you grieve this and
move on from this what does that make
possible because you're willing to
change with your season so i love how
you were talking about that earlier dave
of something dying means that something
new can grow and that's exciting too
steve and melanie are on these debt-free
stage right here in the lobby where you
guys live
we're huntington beach california oh i
was just there i was in anaheim okay
i just just spoke at a church over there
this weekend it was wonderful so hey
guys so how much debt have you paid off
we paid off 1 million wow
78 000.
what
yeah that has not happened yet today
i need this story
amazing how long did this take it took
us four years and two months oh my gosh
what's your household income range
during that time we went from 180 to
just under 250. cool what do y'all do
for a living
i'm a registered nurse in the emergency
department oh yeah and i'm a
construction project manager for a
commercial real estate company i'm both
rather busy right now oh wow my goodness
gracious wow okay so what kind of debt
was this
we had seven mortgages so we're just
slightly leveraged
and that included five out-of-state
rental properties we had a
home up in the eastern sierras melanie
had lived in mammoth lakes for about 27
years and so we had
her home up there and then when we got
married seven years ago then we had the
the home down in huntington beach that
that i had been in wow
so what'd you do start amputating
amputating properties yeah so we had the
uh we had the seven mortgages and then
we also had uh school loans that for
melanie's nursing school credit card and
then uh furniture on a zero percent
interest oh yeah oh yeah
that was our gift to ourselves for our
two year anniversary
i love it
we don't have enough debt let's get some
more that's right
so we did all the things did you sell a
bunch of the properties is that what
you're saying we we actually did so we
we went through uh financial peace
through our church in 2017
and we started working the steps but
with the amount of debt we we started
hitting the school loan debt and uh in
the credit card and furniture loans so
we we kind of hit that hard but hadn't
really
looked at selling the properties just
yet and what really kind of
triggered that was i started listening
to the podcast in 2019 and it got me
really
fired up based on what hearing you talk
about the uh
when things are all going smooth
everything's great but if you have a
little bit of a hiccup there then
everything can can turn you not
looking at the risk so i think that was
a big one for me
and so we we just started looking at it
and decided you know let's unload
the properties the the five out of state
properties and uh when we started really
kind of shifting we just really felt god
kind of led us with that because
everything just went really quickly and
wow super smooth we we basically sold
those properties immediately and then
covet hit so had we owned all those rent
dependent properties during covid you'd
have been screwed we'd have been
homeless yeah yeah well and i got laid
off after almost 15 years yeah so that
happened right in the midst of due to
covet i was laid off so if we had had
seven mortgages we it could have been
catastrophic for us yeah yeah so we put
everything back on our primary residence
and then we just started hitting that
hard and that's when i got on board
because i could we were so deep
that i couldn't i couldn't even see a
bit of light anywhere so i couldn't get
on board i just wasn't a fan of i mean
no offense but
it's a million dollars i'm not offended
this whole thing was too much i was like
there's just no way there's just no way
i had 60 000 just real quick 60 000 in
student loans that i'd been paying on
for four or five years that were more
than when i started sure
yeah
that's the blessing of student life
that's the blessing it just keeps on
giving yeah
and so with the podcast something that
was um really good information as you
had mentioned not trying to like i got
fired up and said okay we've got to do
this but i go i get i've got to tread
lightly because if i want to get melanie
on board you know i need to bring her on
board willingly i'm not going to be able
to force this and so we
you know really coming up having uh
having a why getting intentional and um
and just
making that decision that you know we
want to make a real
um you know take a bite out of this this
debt wow i mean you guys are incredible
so so you had this turn around
what what kept you motivated how did you
stay with it for this long haul to get
through all that you said you couldn't
see any light when did you start to see
some light
after we sold all of our properties and
put it down on our primary residence and
i think we were down to like 160. okay
and that's like wow that's huge and he
he um had lost his job and got a big
severance and and so then we're thinking
oh if we put that on if you get another
job if this if that and everything just
kind of lined up he got another job god
just laid the way and we just kind of
took the steps and it just it just blew
up the whole thing and then coveted yeah
so then i i you know obviously i could
work as much as i want so i took two
full-time jobs worked six 12-hour shifts
a week
for ten months and uh
six twelves effort yeah and uh
yeah
so that was because we have the why yeah
but as soon as the like i was trying to
see it now yeah and now there was life
and so once i was on board there was
just no it was like steamroll it was it
was a little bit like a wildfire with
wind once once she was on board it's
like i'll work you know as much as
possible
you guys are amazing i'm so proud of you
what the beautiful part of this story is
just the
the holy spirit whispering to you
at just exactly the right time
like three years before you had to yeah
and and you would have been you'd have
been messed up i mean and he just
completely saved you you're listening
saved you but he saved you that's
amazing i'm so proud of y'all very well
done all right it is steve and melanie
from los angeles a million 78 000 paid
off in four years and two months count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
i love it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 21 31 the
horse is made ready for the day of
battle but victory belongs to the lord
henry ford said if i had asked people
what they wanted they would have said
faster horses
that's the theme of the horses there we
go still there
all right joanna is with us joanna is
with us in philadelphia hi joanna
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you for having me sure um i
i graduated college last year and my
student loan payments begin in march of
next year
i'm responsible for paying back my
student loan debt as well as the parent
plus loan that i took out under my
mother's name which is about a total of
72 thousand dollars
my brother suggested that i look into
the resources that you offer and i'm
basically just trying to figure out how
to go about paying both
loans at the same time while keeping up
with my financial responsibilities and
getting paid a salary of 32 000 a year
well that last number makes it tough
doesn't it
yes
yeah
so what do you do
um i work as an appeals clerk for a
federal government agency i get paid
about
17 um an hour i have good benefits for
1k and all that stuff
okay and what's your degree in
i graduated with a degree in
communication arts and digital
filmmaking
okay so you're not working in your field
no okay
what's your plan
well right now i'm looking into
possibly finding a a job that pays more
because i'm living paycheck to paycheck
you know this is my first year um living
alone
and i have to already start thinking
about like a plan of paying back the the
loans
while keeping up with all my other
payments okay all right
and how much of the 70 000 is in your
name and how much of it's in your mom's
name
um under my name is about 29
and under my mom's name is thirty eight
thousand um interest of five thousand
um
but she just got a mortgage
um about two years ago so i'm pretty
much responsible for paying back was
under her name
and that was your deal all along right
right so you invested 70 80 000 into a
degree
and um
you're going to need to benefit from
that degree
by using it to get a better job than you
have now
so that you can pay off this debt does
that make sense
yes
so i want you really to work on the
career side
of this equation i'm glad you've got
what you've got but there are no
benefits in the world good enough to
make what you have to be called a good
job
right you just got a job
it's not a good job
it's not a good job okay
a good job in your world is you're gonna
make 60 to 80.
okay
and you can do that it might not be
instantaneously but i don't want you
five years from now sitting in that same
place you're sitting in now because it's
where you happened to land the first
month you got out of college and you
never did anything about it
right does that make sense because you
as you have found the 32 is tough to
live on much less reduce 70 000 worth of
debt much less even pay the payments on
it
so you're looking at extra jobs right
now just to break even aren't you
yeah yeah
okay so what i'm telling you
has to make sense you've got to work on
the career side and i'll help you with
that we're gonna we have a ramsey
personality named ken coleman that helps
people find their best way to move into
a career
and uh we have a career assessment that
we charge thirty dollars for i'm gonna
give it to you free
we have
a book that he wrote called the
proximity principle which is going to be
a big deal for you
and i'm going to give it to you for free
and i want you to do both of those
things this week i want you to finish
the book and finish the assessment both
this week
okay
and then i want you on ken coleman.com
and downloading his resume templates and
start listening to his podcast because
what you have more than a student loan
crisis would be an income crisis
does that make sense to you
yes sir
because obviously if we can double your
income you can get out of this pretty
quick
yeah
joanna if i'm you i'm i'm right now
looking at this as if i'm taking on two
part-time jobs one part-time job
literally anything to get some some
extra income coming in right now
immediately like this weekend and the
second part-time job is looking for a
career change i'm looking at it that way
you're going to get immediate income and
a part-time job to give you some
breathing room and then in addition to
that you are going all in on exactly
those resources dave just talked about
searching making connections doing
everything you can to get a better
full-time job that's going to make you
more money
and it may take a little bit longer to
do that that's fine because you're going
to have a little bit of margin from this
other part-time job and i don't want you
worrying about benefits yeah
you're broke
i want you to worry about money
so the next time someone asks you about
your career and what you're getting paid
i want you to say i make money
[Laughter]
okay because if you make sixty thousand
dollars a year and there aren't any
benefits i think you'll be okay
now and there will be some benefits
probably unless you're doing contract
stuff but i mean you know if we can get
you a 60 70 80 get you on the track in
the communications world in the film
world whatever it is you've been
studying whatever your dream was that
caused you to go get that degree then
you can move in the right direction
so very cool kelly i'll pick up and get
you signed up for everything you call us
or ken back anytime and we'll be honored
to walk with you and help you do all
this it's an income issue for you kiddo
all right justin is in mason city iowa
hi justin how are you
i'm good thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
um i have a question i have
i'm debt free my wife and i are debt
free
um finally paid off my student loans
after listening to your show and not
waiting for
the government bailout
so
i did that but my question is
we have a mortgage still
and we owe 152
000 on our mortgage and we have some
mutual funds that we could take um money
out of the mutual funds but we're
worried about the
tax bill on the
mutual funds counting it towards income
well how long have you had the mutual
fund
um in december it will be considered
long-term gain
and so that would be that would only be
a 15 tax right
right right right
and how much how much of the money how
much is in the mutual fund
we have about 400 000 okay and so if you
pull 200 out how much is the gain on the
200 how much has the has it gained
um that i'm not sure it's only been a
year it couldn't have been much
right right and the tax is only on the
gain
okay and so if you're if you're 200 000
went up 20 000 bucks your taxes are
three grand
okay
so it's nothing
yeah no that's nothing
that's not right you did that wrong i
did that wrong no if it went up if it
went up twenty thousand bucks it's three
grand no i did do that right twenty
thousand not two hundred thousand that's
right yeah
yeah so fifteen percent of your gain is
all you're paying taxes on that's the
whole thing okay and so yeah you're
gonna use that and pay off this house
that's awesome man but i might wait till
december and hit the long-term capital
gains and cut your tax bill in half
yeah okay
all right yeah if you wait from
september to december and it costs you
three grand instead of six grand that's
probably a good idea
yeah all right
okay
that's that's what we were thinking um
and we just didn't know
uh
you know what the taxes were going to
really be on it i knew it was 15 but i
didn't know how to figure out that it's
only on how much it went up
and if it's only a year old it couldn't
it shouldn't have gone up that much does
that make sense well well some of it is
a year old some of it is older some of
it's um it
on the part that's older you don't have
to wait
okay
and but you may have a little more
capital gain on that part and so you
talk with your broker and figure out
which is the most tax efficient portion
to cash out to pay off your mortgage and
then i would get after it and do that
thank you for calling take back your
time this is the last day to get all the
deals all the add-ons before the book
hits the
streets tomorrow check it out chrissy
wright's brand new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to a balanced
life be sure and check it out christy
good hour thanks for having me
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you